صلاه المتحده باتت حزينه وبائسه ووضعها
يدعو الى الحرض وفي افغانستان ربما في
اللحظه الاكثر
احراجا في حياه بلدينا
تخلينا عن 85 مليار دولار من المعدات
العسكريه الافضل من نوعها في العالم وفي
اوكرانيا التي ما كان حربها ستتم ان كنت
انا في السلطه
[تصفيق]
الايفان قدامك شويه
رايتم يفعلون ذلك المره الاخرى
الان اعداءنا يسخرون منا ويتحدثون عنا
بشيء من التحكم والسخريه
وكانت هناك احداث كثيره اليوم فقط اليوم
صاروخ ربما ارسلته روسيا الى بولندا الى
50 ميلا داخل اراضي
البولنديه
والكل غاضب
والكل مشتاق الان
لدينا رئيس
يستسلم للنوم في مؤتمراته عالميه
وتمزراعه من قبل البرلمان البريطاني بسبب
افغانستان
وبس بكلماتي الحكيمه التي التي قالها قال
انه يشكر البلد الخطا الذي دعاه الى مؤتمر
المناخ المناخ اكثر من اي شيء اخر
في الحقيقه ذكر اسم بلد اخر ليس ذلك في
قاره اخرى والان هو يقودنا الى شفا حرب
نوويه وهو مفهوم لم يكن لم يكن احد يزرع
على ذكره قبل سنوات امر مريع وحتى
التغيرات المناخير التي قال انها ستؤثر
علينا بعد 300 عام الان لكل الحديث ينصب
عليها لكن التهديد النوويه الذي هو
التهديد الاقصى لم يتم حتى
الاتيان على ذكره
وايضا على ماذا
ال200 300 عام المقبله يتحدثون عن المناخ
لكن السلاح النووي الذي قد يقضي على بلد
بضربه واحده تم تجاهله
الديمقراطيون الان جعل من بلدنا مقسما
وراكعا في شكل لم يسبق له مثيل لكننا هنا
جئنا لنقول ان الامر لا ينبغي ان يكون
كذلك لا ينبغي ان يكون كذلك
[تصفيق]